comes for people around the world and
especially for people that are on the
lower end of the income scale people in
developing countries and and people in
Middle income countries and advanced
economies that are suffering from uh
from lower incomes and uh from the costs
of climate change for if as as a for
instance and so that's the thrust of the
spring meetings and I wonder crystallina
uh you IMF does a lot of look at the
global economic out Outlook we are
worried about the slowness of growth now
and the prospect that it might stay slow
what do you think and what are the big
challenges well David let me first thank
you for honoring this tradition for us
to start the meetings week together
you're right we are yet again assembling
our membership at the time of high
uncertainty
the recovery
with so much are hoping for a robust
recovery is still a bit elusive
why because
we do have a significant inflation
problem that means
central banks have to continue
to keep interest rates higher to combat
it and that is on the way of restoring
the prospects for robust growth
we have seen that this rapid transition
from low interest rates abundant
liquidity to higher interest rates
and much less available liquidity has
exposed vulnerabilities in the financial
sector that made the task of policy
makers even harder
so in that context what we are
projecting for this year is despite the
remarkable resilience of consumer
spending in the United States in Europe
despite the uplift from China's
reopening Global growth would remain
below 3 percent as we projected it
earlier
this year and what is more concerning
it would remain around three percent for
the next five years
that does not give us High Hope
for meeting the aspirations of people
especially poor people around the world
and most importantly poor people in poor
countries let me stress three issues in
that context the first one is that this
picture of growth is Divergent there are
Emerging Markets that are doing better
but
for Frontier markets for the poor
countries
the future is not so bright and in terms
of income per capita growth
poor countries would remain below income
per capita growth in middle-income
countries
dangerous Divergence
to
we have been wrestling with one crisis
after another another one shock after
another and that has pushed on the back
burden the longer term agenda of
structural reforms that are Paramount to
uplift productivity
and with productivity remaining low the
prospects for growth are low and three
the verbs that tie us together
have become weaker over the last years
fragmentation is deepening and what it
means is that what has generated
tremendous impetus for growth and
prosperity over the last three decades
an integrated economy is being
negatively impacted we have done
research at the IMF that shows that
just the cost of trade fragmentation can
run as high as seven percent of global
GDP over the years
so these meetings are an opportunity for
us not only to talk about the immediate
priorities of restoring price stability
and safeguarding financial stability but
also about the longer term prospects of
growth and how Prosperity can be an
achievable objective for the lower
income countries
which takes me to you how do you see
that
exactly right and as as we look at it
the the elements of growth into the
future uh it's important that there be
more investment uh investment in small
businesses in uh in new businesses uh
and that means a flow of capital and a
worry that we have for developing
countries is the capital inflow the
capital flow right now is out of
developing countries so there's for many
of the developing countries it looks
like they're in a phase of
de-capitalization rather than
recapitalization that goes with your
point that the instead of having
convergence meaning peop the the uh
people with lower incomes growing faster
than people with with higher incomes so
convergence toward a higher level that's
not happening right now it's actually a
Divergence and that's that's Gravely
concerning that means inequality that
means means fragility for countries and
we see more countries falling into
fragility one of the concerns with the
current with high prices now high prices
are being applied to food and fertilizer
and a concern for the poorest around the
world is the farmers are not able to
plant or the the and if they don't get
fertilizer often they won't plant for
the crop cycle because they know that
their yields will be too low uh and so
an urgent need and we've worked on this
over the last six months but it's uh
still has room to come together is that
the fertilizer resources go to the
people that can pay the most and that
means those farmers are providing the
global uh crop supplies and so that's
that's a challenge right now for example
wheat supplies globally are at a low
level China has substantial stockpiles
but most of the other countries have
drawn down uh there are stockpiles and
so that points to a period of uh strain
on Global Food Supplies I wanted to pick
up on your point about uh the trade uh
fragmentation so as we think about that
trade is uh vital to productivity within
the world people uh swapping Goods in
their in their Village in within their
country and across borders is a way to
add value to create more productivity uh
and to the extent that that breaks down
into uh Regional blocks or protectionist
blocks uh that's that's a concern and
right now that's the direction of travel
for the world to to as it as it looks to
stop the globalization and to reverse it
the risk is that it will come out with
uh with unproductive structures uh and
that also will weigh on world growth and
I guess I'll I'll finish on your opening
point point that just to move from very
low interest rates I think artificially
low interest rates and the capital
allocation that went with it meaning
investors all over the world were making
decisions based on the idea that it was
zero percent interest rates for a long
period of time low for long uh and that
misallocated the capital so to bring
that back to productive uses uh is
really hard if you if you say well we're
going to keep the interest rates at
current levels or go to a more normal
levels of interest rates that means
losses for banks that had a duration
mismatch as we saw with Silicon Valley
Bank and so there there's losses being
allocated by the world system now but we
should keep in mind if you just lower
the interest rates back down it won't
solve the problem what that means is
that people will suffer from inflation
uh the dollar weakens the inflation rate
goes back up and that hurts the poor the
most so so I think there has to be a
goal of finding a low inflation
environment and dollar stability for the
future very much agree with that central
banks
do have a preoccupation
to bring inflation down and it is
Paramount because without price
stability
there is no sound foundation for
Investments and for growth
their job has become more complicated
because of the exposure of
vulnerabilities in the financial sector
that means attention has to be paid to
financial stability
fortunately they have different tools
they can apply to deal with these two
different problems
they can fight inflation
by keeping interest rates
higher for longer
and they can provide targeted liquidity
should there be a need to bring down
risks to financial stability
what we have seen is a remarkable
rapid and effective intervention by
policy makers primarily central banks
but not only
Financial authorities supervisory
authorities regulatory authorities once
there was
a problem exposed
they acted sweetly
and this is very different to what
happened
during the global financial crisis
so there is something to celebrate we
learned a lesson react on it
however when we looked into the look
into the future the problem that you
outlined
allocation of capital
it has to be recognized that without the
confidence that productivity is going to
go up
How does it go up it goes up when there
is effective investment in education
skills development
adaptability to changing labor market
needs it gets up when there is effective
investment in research and innovation
and it goes into private sector
performance
it doesn't stay locked into monopolies
that only have access to this uh new
discoveries and productivity goes up
when division of labor that trade
provides is effectively energized I do
hope that as we have these meetings to
talk about the immediate pressing
priorities of price stability Financial
stability we will pay more attention to
how the world can go into a higher
growth path
I apologize this is vital to the world
uh the the getting the growth rate
higher is important for people's jobs
it's important also for the migration
patterns of countries you know if if
we're in a world where people have to
migrate to other countries in order to
have uh access to Capital uh that that
is a challenge and they're being pushed
by climate change they're being pushed
by their own countries having domestic
debt problems uh and so that pressure is
substantial so I think there's an
urgency to the the uh the the policy
changes now I I want to uh inquiry on on
one specific area as the central banks
who raise uh raise interest rates
they've described it as a a goal of uh
of uh reducing demand within the economy
I think there really has to be much more
awareness that the the long-term
solution is through much greater Supply
Ai and that means short-term financing
for small businesses for medium-sized
businesses right now or somehow we fell
into a cycle I think over the last 10
years where the central banks were
buying long maturity assets and that
really fundamentally changed the
direction of the world toward bigness uh
that
governments can issue 10-year bonds
small businesses don't issue 10-year
bonds and so one of the things I hope we
could do is really have a clear view how
do you get back to a world where
short-term financing is available to
businesses they're not there I very much
agree with this David it matters to
everyone it matters a lot
two emerging markets and developing
economies
we know that in emerging markets and
developing economies
if the small and medium-sized
Enterprises are suffocated
there is simply no way to generate the
jobs a growing population
demands from this in these countries so
that question of how we think about
financing accessibility to finance for
everyone especially for women-led
businesses something that the World Bank
has researched for quite some time this
is this is again on the list of issues
that got pushed down
because of this shock upon shock upon
shock and I want to say
we cannot
finish this conversation without
recognizing that one of these shocks the
senseless war in Ukraine
can go away
by just a decision
taken by the country that invaded
Ukraine to stop the war
why that matters why that matters what
what we are discussing here because one
this war has distracted the world's
attention from many other pressing
problems
this war not only kills people
it is pushing up food prices you talked
about it
and it is creating more geopolitical
tensions pushing down the ability of the
world to work as one so I want to
recognize there is a problem there that
these meetings cannot resolve but it
would help tremendously with the agenda
we are discussing if it gets resolved it
would and the horror of the the war is
ever present and uh uh as you know it's
uh the world's gone from the covered uh
pandemic to now this uh also horrible
um uh development and outcome and uh
lasting longer and longer uh than than
people had hoped we've been involved as
you know in in uh helping Channel World
uh resources to the to the civilian
sector of Ukraine uh as a as a
maintenance operation and we're also
looking at the recovery uh side of the
Ukrainian economy and you we're we're
talking in shorthand to an extent
because we'd see each other regularly
and often talk about uh structural
reforms and the upside opportunity that
countries have if they can find stronger
fiscal policies stronger uh
yes that means taxes but we look at
systems to have a broader base for the
taxes rather than higher rates ways that
allow the country the people of the
country to have more economic activity
uh and so that's the daily chores of
World Bank and IMF of uh how do we
interact with Ethiopia with Egypt with
Nigeria with South Africa countries that
are looking for a Direction with turkey
with uh and and on I I didn't mean to
mention just a few with a hundred
countries around the world how do we
work uh together really to find a path
for the country that has better growth
on the other side and the challenge is
the burdens keep adding up the burden of
debt the burden of climate costs the
burden of uh of uh the higher food
prices all of those add up substantially
so we're had a bit of a liquidity crunch
for the poorer countries and also this
longer term problem of where do you get
growth we know where it comes from
productivity from new investment but the
Stars aren't aligned right now to
achieve that well this is why it is good
that twice a year we can all get
together and then concentrate on what we
can do by better coordination of our
members and of course of our
institutions
I want to bring a an element of
positivism in this discussion yes it is
a very difficult time
but if we look back in what we have
achieved over the last
three years three and a half years
it is a lot uh David one
we have managed to come together very
early when the covet hit
and collectively the members themselves
taking the appropriate policy actions
and our institutions
financing those that had no access to
other sources of financing
that managed to bring the impact of
covet economically
much further down than it would have
been otherwise I remember our first
assessment of the risks of the covet
crisis was 10 contraction of the world
economy didn't happen 3.1 is not nothing
but it is far from 10 contraction I
remember you and I discussing how we can
coordinate actions on financial terms
how we go together our very first loan
was to Kyrgyzstan kyrgy's Republic one
week hour after who
announced the covet pandemic since then
we have financed 96 countries never in
the history of the IMF we have done so
much for so many and we have done that
together with you we have recognized
that as a problem I want to give you the
credit for being such a strong voice
including your latest block
on behalf of countries that find
themselves
crushed by the burden of death we have
called for the debt service suspension
initiative and now we are in these
meetings David and I am so very pleased
we can tell our audience
we are not letting our guard down on
this issue we are going to have the
global sovereign debt Roundtable
bringing for a first time
all creditors
traditional new public private with the
debt countries and and we does the key
institutions so we can sit around the
table
and find solutions to what otherwise can
be devastating for countries
so we have done things together that
would have been much less effective if
we didn't have that platform to
everybody coming to the meetings
row your sleeves let's continue in that
Spirit of getting things done
and since this is the last time I have
this pleasure of sitting with you at the
start of the meeting sir David
what is your hope for the future
what do you see on the horizon for our
institutions what is the wisdom you
would like to pass to all who are
watching and of course uh to to to to
the Grateful me
that's that's awfully nice uh and I I
pick up the word wisdom out so I I don't
know if I can achieve that but I'm going
to share a little bit I'm going to go
from the small to the large
um four years ago yesterday I walked
into the atrium here as president of the
World Bank uh and you were a Mainstay of
global development uh and for then at
the world bank now at the uh IMF and one
of our uh uh one of our challenges was
to try to find breakthroughs in
countries uh that was my hope you know I
we I always had the vision of how do we
get better outcomes for people in
developing countries but then we
recognized that a way to do that was to
have of individual breakthroughs or
Regional breakthroughs some new insight
whether it be in the area of currencies
or of fiscal policy or of trade policy
or of uh uh uh uh infrastructure
development so I'm still working to get
breakthroughs one of the ones we worked
on early was Ethiopia we saw that the uh
the the Dual exchange rate they they
have an official exchange rate which is
available to the few and a parallel
market exchange rate that is very
expensive for the rest uh within the
country and it has not worked very well
I took I went to Ethiopia in early on in
May of 2019. you went I think in August
of 2019 and we will again be tackling
that in the debt Roundtable or and in
our meetings this week to see if there
can be a breakthrough because uh the
number of people's lives that are at
stake is huge I don't know I I didn't
look up but Ethiopia may have 120
million people it's a large number and
growing uh and so uh creating a better
future for them uh is both a macro
Challenge and then a micro challenge
letting more imports and exports flow in
and out uh through better systems is
going to be vital for their growth and
getting their living standards higher so
I wanted to start on you know a lot of
what we've done over these my my four
year four years uh it has been on
specific countries and regions how do
you Pro solve problems uh in various
parts of the world but then that that
has confronted this giant macro overlay
of the world of uh covid slow growth
Rising interest rates and uh the the
Russia's invasion of Ukraine uh all of
all of that conspiring in a way uh to
give not enough money for any of the
goals that uh that we have for people in
developing countries so I feel good
about uh you know it was a it's been a
very busy four years and prior to that
uh at the U.S treasury uh working on
similar issues uh at a very rapid pace
so I feel good about that very good
about the World Bank uh uh group the the
the all of our all of our entities uh
but also
um uh worried I guess I'll say frankly
about prospects for people in developing
countries there's there's not a good
Avenue I like your point of optimism we
have technology we have institutions
that care uh we have uh uh uh uh enough
there's enough money in the world
there's enough capital in the world to
make it work but my concern is it's all
absorbed into a small group and it it's
uh not working right now and it takes
some fundamental changes in order to
make it work it's been a pleasure
working with you through these four
years I am I'm very confident that
Solutions will be found
it is a matter of
will
and then you find a way I always
remember in the context of these
conversations when we have a very steep
mountain to climb what Nelson Mandela
once said impossible until it is done
and I really look forward to engaging
with our membership during this week
David engaging with you with our
partners at the World Bank because if we
can imagine
a world in which
the tremendous
capital
the wealth that is created
is put for the bigger public good
in which we
open up opportunities for everyone to
reach their full potential
in which we deal with the tremendous
challenge of climate change
then
we can say
Mandela is right
all of these things that we discussed
that are so difficult
impossible until they are done the great
theme for our challenging week ahead we
we we each have 15 hard meetings I don't
know you may have 25 hard meetings ahead
this week but with a clear uh goal uh
and so uh enjoy where you can I'll try
to do the same and uh we're launching
our our week of spring meetings yes
right and I can see that our
gracious host is looking at us with this
sign that says your time is up thank you
for that fantastic conversation thank
you president Malpass MDK your Geva you
have indeed provided us with some
insightful context on the major issues
that will be on your plate this week and
with that we come to the end of this
event but there is more to come you can
watch this replay as well as other
events throughout the week on
live.worldbank.org forward slash spring
meetings 2023 we hope you've enjoyed
hearing from our distinguished guests
today but please continue your comments
online with the hashtag reshaping and
development we would love to hear from
you I'm noriana Fernando and thank you
for joining us
foreign
[Music]